welcome to this video playing on the
national master is at 79 from Finland I
keep forgetting the name at played him
so often Antipholus a low okay um we've
got a calc on this chat line with c4
we're way forgotten the theory and why
white takes on d5 and has some next upon
at least in temporarily like is trying
to get it back maybe I'm managing away
it's got Bishop f4 okay let's let's get
at me and see if this really is an issue
we have to show perform if I go Bishop
e7 Bishop f4 see 80s got a foursome this
is a problem yeah but I need to get this
I need to get this pawn before Bishop f4
mmm and then I look move this looks
really likes looks very strange
okay i need to i need to to look at some
point Bishop f5 and I thought maybe Luke
b7 as weird as it looks yeah this is
strange this is really strange hmm maybe
Bishop f4 be said if he goes a 4 I maybe
have before attending Queen takes before
interesting interesting just going for
the week square the plate we should be
seven hours also d6 but i have e cigs
but then it can maybe second be five
plus of course after we should be 7s
knight c6 which is potentially very very
good yeah that's not great not not not
nice okay i know it looks at it looks
very very strange I don't only what I
cannot play but should be 796 and take
at the end I cannot grab d4 because of
which should be three year this is just
terrible I mean the whole position is
probably terrible the question is can he
can he even sacrifice already on b5 it's
possible that the sir that this is
working already I don't really think so
but maybe it is possible
very ugly position yeah I really forgot
how this is played it's a very tricky
line for both sides something that white
players i could investigate because it's
very small um yeah it's very small on
margin for error therefore black and if
you don't know what you're doing you get
this kind of strange position I'm not
sure how bad it really is but it it's
not not not nice okay may Allah thought
before I bishop a6 even maybe just
bishop a six Wow Queen takes last night
d 5 this is probably okay yeah but this
la ugly takes c3 takes b7 hmm yeah well
but what can you do i need to a neato so
Bishop e7 now there's also a five but
not much not much that I can do to avoid
that so if i go queen d five maybe Queen
B 6 yeah this is maybe this is available
Queen B 6 and then I have Queen g2 or
something along these lines I Scott
Queen B 5 check hmm that's very
unfortunate
compy five yeah well I came not much not
much choice anyway check yeah it's got
97 but I don't know I didn't see
anything else I think you can just play
rook everyone I mean maybe he's got
something better concrete concrete play
with nine f7 but just you have one that
I don't really see a see a moose Queenie
for this should be three it's not really
leading to anything
still might have 70 okay I don't really
see a movie so can might as well just
play play one
young Bishop again he can take whatever
Bishop takes it's all winning it's all
winning Bishop takes Queen you [ __ ]
you too and I don't even have a check so
but Queen takes is also also possible
Bishop a six would be nice but the squid
be a check made now almost checkmate
maybe yeah maybe that he goes Knight f
78 9 h8 a half Bishop a six and i'm
getting the rook here with nice play he
can win in various fashion various ways
if it takes I'm and maybe can play
Bishop a six SSSs may be possible I
didn't really expect that one but why
not actually i'll take here
it was his King is also a slight
liability so this is why I'm not
resigning maybe some tricks but
ultimately I'm I'm lost here check oh
this is nice okay check check I'm hoping
on shiny for my morning okay i just got
a queen trade her game black resigned
yeah this was a really bad here i'm
already in big trouble I guess but I
really forgot how how this is played
probably a 6 is already nonsense yeah of
course of course yeah what white usually
plays Bishop beehive and I forgot about
that then you can weigh 6 yeah yeah I
should just play g6 yes I completely
forgot how this is played just g6 Bishop
g7 castles and then see what what
happens this is this is just just
unplayable and he very convincingly
refuted that I think yeah 95 is just
strong and well this is this is very
ugly but I mean this is just just from
just terrible aim Bishop f4 is good but
that's just what's this I cannot get
this back that I cannot take here I mean
maybe maybe I can but other company
wants to sacrifice him with a win for
white yeah with this kind of moves
coming yeah it's terrible terrible
and this is just just wow yeah well but
he played this very convincingly I guess
all this is just strong check too I
guess there's absolutely no play at all
the diet that I can know absolutely
nothing yeah very nice very nice game by
him and an important reminder that you
cannot play this this type of stuff ok
thanks for watching